the first time we do a livestream
actually so should be interesting
okay thanks thanks everyone so I believe
were were life so I want to thank
everybody who's who's watching us and
you know the attendance was here but
also the people who are life actually we
were very excited to see how many people
were interested in what we have to say
today you know we had lots of interest
on social media and the like so to
interest myself I'm carrying Bagheera
I'm the co-founder and CEO of insta team
instead deep is an AI startup which is
focused on really delivering innovative
products and the sort of like pushing
the envelopes of what can be done and so
as you know today we have a surprise we
didn't want to reveal you know what what
it was about so without waiting further
I am very happy to introduce you to our
new product which is this one
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so for the first time we're happy thank
you we're very excited to tell you more
about deep PCB so basically you know
this is an electronic design automation
product and we're very excited about it
actually we believe it is the first
we've we've checked the third the first
like PCB rotor which actually looks at
solving this problem using pure AI so
this is end to end a I know many in the
loop purely cloud-based and you know I
want to thank all the team who's worked
very very hard to make this a reality
and together with Nabil or leader
hardware engineer we're going to tell
you more about what's going on there
so let's look into what we have so first
I want to explain why we decided to
focus on this specific problem like you
know there are many uses of AI but why
we thought this problem was really
compelling I mean it really comes in the
end from you know what is happening and
what are the needs of users so let me
take an example on this ATM board so
this is what we call a printed circuit
board so it is a component of
electronics that you find in pretty much
all products and which is which is key
here in this particular case this HTM
board is used for energy concern like
conception and detection and so the
problem that we are looking at is
essentially how do we connect the
different pins and components on the
chip so you can see here the different
lines that are connecting those pins
like how do you connect those and this
is an interesting one and typically on
printed circuit boards you have multiple
layers so this is one layer here and
this is the second layer so typically
you have at least two layers for simple
printed circuit boards but it can be
many more and the interesting point here
is how do I connect those and it's
actually not such an easy problem and if
you look at what the users are saying
this was a bit earlier this year this
was in March of
these were the kind of commands we could
see online so basically people saying
the current auto Reuters are not
spectacular
I usually manually route my PCBs
manually this is really interesting like
you know in 20 like in 2019 with all the
progress of Technology and AI we are
still making those connections manually
and it takes a ton of time this is
actually like one of the comments we
picked up from kick at forum which is a
very active forum for PCB hobbyists
another one in comparison to chess
algorithms routing algorithms seem to be
less developed that's interesting
because there's been a lot of progress
in chess and the game of go as you know
if you've been following the AI news
same thing is most of time I do the joke
when the design is finished 100% and
when we say design finishes usually has
a manual component into this I start the
auto rotor there is rarely over 80% when
Otto Reuter ends like like basically
auto rotor
does not complete all the connections it
usually completes something like 80% of
those connections and we've seen many
many of those commands and I think that
it we have the you know we are lucky to
have both domain expertise in electronic
design but also advanced knowledge of
what AI can do and in particular what
what AI can do that has not been done
and we found this problem
extraordinarily interesting and we
decided year and a half ago to commit
significant resources into looking into
it and possibly finding solutions that
users want so if I am to summarize
what's going on here we are saying that
PCB routing today is very time consuming
because it's done manually and this was
particularly the case when you have like
complex boards it can take weeks if not
months in specific cases using like
specialized Hardware basically engineers
and it relies on human knowledge like
this is really like a case where the
expert sort of have has had a lot of you
know many years spent on the problem and
sort of starting to understand the
intricacies of it so in a sense it's
like
chess champions they have spent years
training and sort of they have this
magic intuition which makes the
difference right and and that's what's
happening in in PCB routing today and
importantly as we said roto-rooter's are
very limited most of them actually use
heuristics which are sort of like like
rules about how to do things the same
way that you know in previous chess
programs and this is before 2017 best
chess programs such as stockfish were a
mix of like computer scientists like
experts in programming but also like
chess champion that would say hey you
should do that and do that and you sort
of program those complex rules that can
be sometimes in the hundreds into a
software which which is efficient so our
approach with deep PCB is to basically
completely you know disrupt and innovate
and when we compare with what is
happening here so first rather than
waiting weeks or months our goal is to
solve printed circuit boards routing in
less than 24 hours or 24 hours at max
this if we managed to do this this would
have a huge impact for users because it
would mean that they can effectively you
know like advance into their development
cycle and there are lots of people
working on different products whether
it's you know like Bluetooth speakers or
any other IOT components all of those
use printed circuit boards if you could
save weeks or months into your
development that is actually something
massive importantly we're also trying to
avoid using heuristics this notion that
hey the human expert knows better has
been true until now but there should be
ways using data-driven advanced
artificial intelligence methods to go
beyond those heuristics and sorts of
rules that actually come from the
experience of people who've been working
on this subject but which are
necessarily limited by the amount of
experience and through time they spent
on it and finally we want something
which is robust we want something which
adapts quickly and ideally like you do
not have to tweak anything everything is
automated and - and you
just basically provide your board 2d PCB
and it does it's magic and this is
basically the work we've been working on
so I'm very excited actually to showcase
for the first time D PCB so this was a
dream a year ago and I'm very excited
that we have reached the moment where
we're doing the beta release so without
waiting further I'm gonna introduce
basically Nabeel Shuba who's our leader
hardware engineer nabil has very
significant expertise into this problem
has worked for more than 15 years into
like elite electronics design companies
some of them have been purchased by
Apple so Anna bill over to you about the
technical side of the project I'm going
to I choose the same book that as a
cream shot in the beginning of the
project is the ATM but it's energy
energy meter well but so what to do it
much of the voltage and the current and
by multiplying the two you get your
consumption so basically the main chip
is here is ATM chip it has bunch of ADCs
and do the sampling and what it do to
also so let's step down the voltage
using other circuit to that that I have
here basically
so the voltage from 12 degree go to to 9
degree line voltage
okay so it has also to enter phase you
have an SPI interface and you have a
square see at the face and so above is
is a bash of component spread spread it
everywhere and for every pin so a
component has pin like this and for
every pin you have a connection so this
pin should be connected to this one
should be connected to this one so you
see the complexity is really enormous we
see this place there is a big congestion
there the job of the guy who is going to
do the routing first he's going to place
the component and next he's going to do
the voting by doing the rod he's going
to connect those points using wires
and say measles so the electronic
engineer they call those rules design
rules and they have a checker automatic
checker that's DSC but when I joined
instead deep so all the guys was ml
researchers so for them it's a game so
they used to play go game and Atari
games so that's why I put the rule of
the game to talk up guys and D a sieve
to talk with electrical guys so
basically when you have wires like this
so the two wires they need to have they
need to be separate by a fixed set space
which is the minimum space we call this
the clearance the other would is that a
wire has a width so you have always to
give to use that width you can use
bigger but you cannot use smaller
because if you smaller the current will
not pass and for the clearance why we
have that clearance it's because you
will have some defect and manufacturing
so you need to see pair of em little bit
LS the they can touch so to improve the
manufacturing yield and other worlds
this as you see here you cannot do
ninety degree you have always to do 45
degree so you can only move by doing 45
degree so here for example he do 45
degree and now what he's doing he put a
via he go from one layer to another
layer so he put a via and a via also it
has a clearance space on that clearance
space you need to be sure that there is
nothing on that area it's like private
space for people once you are sure that
everything is clean you put a via and
you go down and you continue down so
this is on the top this is on the back
if you can see okay so let's move on
okay
usually when we start doing a design the
first thing that you do is you you
search on the internet on all the
components like you are going to do a
Bluetooth Bluetooth board for IOT you
search all the Bluetooth chips and you
select the one that has the resources
that you need for example one ADC 12 bit
plus
akov takes m0 so once you made all your
research so you put your chip you put
your chip and you put other component
that will provide the supply that would
provide the clerk - it's like this one
provide the clerk and you do the
connection every you do the your
connection does have debugging jump-offs
once once you have done this the the
second step is placement so you place
your you place your component on the
boat and the tool automatically know
that this pin is going to be connected
to this one from the chi-o-matic and in
our case what you need to do is that you
need to save this file after placement
you give us the files and we do the auto
voting for you okay so this and this is
the same board as carrying present at
winning is the ATM bar so this is a
solution which fully connect the boat so
this book tells 160 pin it has here is
actually this is the real professional
board that we've seen in the beginning
so what you see here is not sort of a
simulation or like an ideal case this is
actually reality so it means like the
design that we you know this B PCB has
delivered actually can be used by like
electronics engineers to build products
so this is basically the real world and
Nabil has been working monthly with his
team to make sure we comply with all
rules so this is actually a real
production design yep yes it's a real
player that's a real boat and the
complexity is that we need to connect
116 pairs and the hooting that you see
here is the example by is designed by
our auto rotors so if you can see our
auto water he support Multi multi net so
so net which is connected to multi piece
usually it's the ground or the supply
that that is connected to multi pins and
also the yellow thang is is the
clearance so that
player is Azam read the back layer is on
blue and whenever you go to you go down
you put a via and you check the
clearance users okay the other thing
that we see in green here let's keep a
so those those places you should not go
usually it's just a hole for the package
okay so for this book we are able to
fully to fully connect all the wires and
we choose this book because it's it's a
really complex board so we compare our
solution with the available free water
and this is the solution of the
available folder and as you can see he
cannot connect this one and he cannot
connect this one but in our case we
connect them all so we can say our
solution is better than this case then
the the free water that leaves two wires
and connected and you see the solution
is completely different and you can see
from here that that the space of search
is a really big so you can you can do a
lot of permutation and things like that
and you push wires and everything is
going to be different this is this is a
significant milestone for us because one
of the goals when we started the project
there was a big question like could we
get to a level of performance
performance which is equivalent or
better than available free Reuters right
we know that free Reuters and OTO
Reuters that are in the market today are
not enough but that's the first
important benchmark and so we're very
excited about this result the fact that
the PCB can on its own without any
preconditions I'm that you see on the
left has sort of like rules that it
follows and it basically copies them
blindly and always does the same thing
in this particular case the PCB is an AI
powered system that's gonna learn to
solve the board so it's going to explore
potential solutions and refine from
there
so we were not sure when we started this
project that this would be possible and
actually we're very excited and this is
also one of the reasons why we decided
to release the beta version as like we
reach that stage where the
a I system on its own without any sort
of like initial heuristics we don't tell
the system how to solve the problem we
just tell the system what is a good
solution or not once he has come up with
a proposal and just by doing that
getting these kind of results who feels
feels like you know we're very
optimistic about the future like what
those systems can deliver for users
could be fantastic and again this
doesn't need manual tinkering by
engineers the system runs Antoine so for
us this is a significant milestone and
the beauty is that it's based on air l
so if you go and test this boat again on
the web you will find a different
solution because our solution keep
improving over time and also it's a bit
of Russian so we are improving some some
wiring okay so let me do a live demo for
you you know life Jim is always tough so
let's see it's going to work this time
okay so let me try okay
so what I would do I I will start with
kicad okay let me move on so I'm going
to start from from scratch so the box is
unloaded so this is the boat just zoom
just a minute okay so this is the world
so usually what what people do is you
need to export the the placement so you
do export you go to generate the dsm
file you save your file
all right place okay once you done this
you go to our internet side and you doin
your project it's easier you just upload
the file you go to your DSM file that I
have already saved select a file choose
do you call your project something
that's
yes submit so once it's submitted what
our platform will do it will generate a
picture of your board and put it on the
system that you see that it's submitted
and it will keep updating with the poor
guys so it will send you a file okay so
let's check again so this is the book
that we have submitted
yep okay so he needs some hours to find
the completely Wyatt completely
connected solution also what he tried to
do is he optimize the number of vias and
also he tried to optimize the land so he
reduced the last okay so let me check
another blog for you because we cannot
stay wait for an hour okay so usually
when you send your blog you will get a
picture like this so this box is
finished as you can see the welding is
already done okay
and you can have also a 3d picture okay
you can turn it and you can see the
wiring on 3d okay and I'll tell you how
many connected wires you have so it's
fully connected both all of the wires
are connected it provide you with the
SES file as the file session spectra
file you load this file and what you do
is you go back to your ki CAD tool back
to kicad do you import the SES file that
we generate for you and port spectra SES
file this one okay okay and you have
your voting already the other step
you have to do is also you need to fill
the plane so we should we support plane
and that's it so this is a full
demonstration of kicad we are also
working we have we are also working on
anti grating a plugin in kicad so that
you don't always connect to our side and
come back and go to the side save the
file and everything so we have here
plug-in that you can see here lets
implemented
yep this one let me make it smaller so
yeah this one so those are the two
plugin that we are so you can send the
file and once the file is ready it gets
uploaded and i'll show you the solution
and and also to animation for you we are
going to release this plug-in in the
future but currently work by using the
platform's so importantly so all of this
is available today so if you connect to
G PCB dot AI you will find the website
where you can upload your boards just
create a login and you can upload your
boss maybe we can show the website it's
very easy just to give you a sense so
it's really as simple as it should be
you have your file in this case we use
DSM format which is ready just upload
your board wait for 24 hours and again
you're saving significant amount of time
compared to weeks if not months in
certain cases and then you just download
the solution and it still works with the
tools you used to which is keycard and
open source tools so that means that you
know you don't have to change your
working habits you know we've worked a
lot on creating those plugins such that
immediately like the solution you get is
compatible with existing open
infrastructure so we believe that the
solution going forward in PCB routing
and electronic design is a mix of you
know advanced tools such as D PCB but
also like open-source tools and making
sure they work well together so that you
can get maximum results effectively yeah
and and maybe we can show the front of
the website like the PCB dot AI just to
give you a sense of what we have yeah so
this is to show you so the website is as
available now you can you can actually
go to
get out you know we've worked on with
our partners and I'll mention that but
really it's as simple as upload you know
wait for 24 hours and download and you
have all the specs here and you can
register there so we were just opening
it now as we speak to basically the
electronics design community and PCB
hobbyists engineers and would be very
interested in their feedback you know
the goal of this exercise is also to
communicate to explain what's the you
know the potential with artificial
intelligence but also to get back
feedback because we believe we are the
beginning of the journey and there's a
lot of like lots of exciting things
coming coming next so maybe I can we can
say a few words about the technology
behind all of this so yeah maybe an
ability one at say what usually releases
yeah yeah as I said this release is a
better version so let's keep improving
over time on the next village you are
trying to support more complex Bo
currently we support only block that is
200 pin and 150 WestEd weighted nest so
all the future we are going to improve
that time we are going to ship off
Bigelow we only support two layers for
for now we are working on supporting the
differential pairs and much impedance
wires what it means it means that
sometimes you have to connect two to two
wires and the length of the two they
should be the same so this is currently
is not supported we also we want to work
and improve our planes super and the
other thing is we are working on making
the wait time when you send your book
the way currently the wait time is is
like two hours three hours and till 24
hours but you are working on it produced
by ten times so thanks a lot
Nabila well done
[Applause]
okay so we survived the live demo so so
let's let's maybe they speak a little
bit about what's the tech behind behind
all this because we believe it's a very
exciting time in AI and particularly
like in advanced applications of AI so
really like I believe what's the
deciding factor in technologically here
is reinforcement learning and deep
reinforcement learning using like
basically neural networks so we've seen
incredible progress in this space it
started of course with you know the
original deep mind result about Atari
games with a breakout displayed here on
the on the bottom right that you see and
then progressively getting better and
better results today open AI has reached
significant results about hand
manipulation using deeper realm
including basically solving Rubik's Cube
so this is remarkable
and of course there's been this
fantastic result using first like with
alphago and then alpha zero showing that
basically methods that don't have
heuristics that are fundamentally based
on deep reinforcement learning and AI
can actually crap crack compare
combinatorially large problems such as
go which was thought to be unsolvable so
just very briefly for the audience which
is maybe not familiar with deep
reinforcement learning a difference for
smart learning is really the concept of
trial and error I am an agent here I'm
basically the PCB trying to solve and
root a board a PCB board I have multiple
actions and then when I do actions which
is in the physical case trying to do
routing different connections between
pins the environment is gonna tell me
okay now the system has changed maybe in
the past you could pass through this way
no you can't anymore because there are
two layers that are blocking your path
there so you get back we want an
observation and reward in this
particular case is really a function of
how good of a solution you get so it
sounds like a simple principle but if
you iterate it at scale this is where
magic happens and people have been
skeptical of deeper enforcement learning
early on but
I believe we are now at a time where
this technology is considered really
liked as a mainstay of modern AI and
we're seeing like bigger and better
applications of it all the time and we
believe this is important because what's
the difference between this versus
classical optimization solvers that are
used in electronic design for example
the difference is that you know if you
are using heuristics it's gonna be fast
but it's gonna be ultimately limited and
the main limitation is the absence of
learning so we can you can see the
situation as the following you have
complex electronic boards and chips to
route and and potentially also place in
the future and the question is like
you're going to deploy massive compute
try to find a good solution and we know
there are lots of different algorithms
that have been applied in this area for
a long time like simulated annealing and
others but the question is if you do
that you could basically you burn a
massive compute budget and maybe next
time around you're going to do the same
and you would have learnt nothing so
it's like you've used that compute
budget just to get to a particular
result that you've learnt nothing new
and I think that if we fundamentally
believe that you know the world is
changing because now you have methods
that literally learn every time they
perform an action so in a sense it's a
bit like humans like you like human
experts if you are you know like a
trainee you're going to learn a lot in
the early days and then through the
years you're gonna become an expert etc
so it's like every time you've done it
like whether it's like routing boards or
any other like playing chess or playing
go every time you play you get better
your intuition gets stronger you have a
more natural sense on intuition about
where you should go and this is what we
believe is super exciting about deep
reinforcement learning it's the ability
for the system effectively to build its
own intuition well what we call
intuition which is basically digesting
past experience and making sure you will
use it in the future in a good way and
so those systems particularly with
exponential progress in compute have
like significant potential and at
Institute with
at the forefront not only of the
research about these systems but also
their applications so I'm mentioning
here some of the results we we got we
started as a start-up with literally
like two laptops and $2,000 but we were
passionate about AI and through time we
started like you know innovating we got
our first papers accepted that the you
know the new rips deep reinforcement
learning workshop in 2018 and this year
were very honored to have been accepted
in your first joint collaboration with
google deepmind you know google deepmind
today is considered as one one of the
leading you know AI companies in the
world together with Google AI and the
simple fact that Institute can
collaborate with deep lines and
importantly get good results we not only
did we get accepted at new reps which is
the largest AI conference but we got
accepted with distinction with a top 2%
ranking globally and a spotlight
presentation so we have this ability to
innovate and actually we had the
opportunity also to meet with David
silver and several like you know
scientists from from deep mind during
the in dhaba and we were very surprised
that the inventor of alphago and alpha
zero actually mentioned publicly or work
as innovative and this is really like
what we're excited about that instead of
how can we bring innovative research
into applications and what you see today
d PCB that we are basically presenting
to the world for the first time is the
result of this effort of combining
innovative AI research with practical
applications and domain expertise and it
wouldn't have been possible without the
domain expertise again we are you know
we're super excited to have fantastic
people like Nabil and his team and in
total we have 30 plus years of
experience in the team of people who've
been working in electronic design in
electronics companies such as the micro
electronics sajama and others so it is
the combination of domain expertise in
this particular field with innovative do
you know AI innovation around deep
reinforcement learning
that makes it possible for a small
start-up like insta deep to innovate and
literally build something that has not
been done to our knowledge we believe
this is a world first and you know and
we believe this is very interesting
because it opens up many opportunities
and in particular there is a lot of
technology tech tech innovation we are
under the hood so very proud also that
the team has basically now four patents
pending yeah patents there
so we're we're we're excited about that
and importantly this has not this would
not have been possible without our
partners we are you know blessed to have
amazing partners in in tech of course
google deepmind is one of them I
mentioned the groundbreaking work we do
with deep mind and in general great
collaboration with the Google AI and
Google developer ecosystem teams so our
infrastructure and product is based on
tensor flow it is cloud native so from
day one all our infrastructure is
actually leveraging in this particular
case Google cloud and we believe there
is a lot of like exciting developments
we're going to do our own cloud and
importantly it leverages also the
expertise and the great like scientific
and technical collaboration we have it
in study instead deep has today for
Google machine learning developer
experts I was the first but I'm not the
first anymore we have three young
talents in in Africa actually who are
today Google machine learning like
Google ml developer experts and that
expertise we re inject into the products
we do such as deep PCB so this is
important because the PCB is a cloud
native product it can run literally on
the cloud if it can have as many and can
scale pretty much linearly with as many
demands as you want to cover and this
makes a huge difference and we also
worked a lot with our partners in
hardware so I wanna mention NVIDIA has
been a great partner to us and who
recently nominated us an elevated
Institute to the highest like ranking in
terms of collaboration we are now a
preferred partner within
this means that we collaborate actively
we're also users of basically nvidia
gpus and particular nvidia
supercomputers so we have dgx
supercomputers in-house at in study and
we can bring you know that expertise and
efficiency that we have through our
collaboration to Nvidia to our products
and customers so when it comes to GPU
computing which is another critical
aspect of the work we do in Indy PCB
we're really very happy of the you know
sustained collaboration we have with
Nvidia but finally we also are in this
particular case and in the parallel
strong users of CPU this might sound a
bit more unintuitive because people tend
to think that hey yeah it's all about
GPUs or cloud CPUs and the like but
actually you need a lot of CPU to
generate experiences again deep
reinforcement learning is all about how
do i generate experiences have agents
who play the game and ultimately we
incorporate those insights into better
models and I'm very proud that we have a
great collaboration with Intel through
the AI builders program so instead deep
is also part of the AI builder programs
and that tight integration translates
for example into new results we've
published and the latest already
conference with Intel where we showcase
that we could improve basically
performance on Intel's Aeons and the
like but you know if you want to
innovate in deep tech I believe as a
start-up you need to come up with your
own like disruptive technology and you
know innovation but you also need to
collaborate with you know the leading
tech players in the ecosystem as we said
Google Nvidia and Intel and today we
have that and this allows us to innovate
faster and bring those disruptive
products to our users so today we are
the beta release what that means is that
you know we're opening this to the
public and we would be very happy to
have you have some feedback on that so
literally the PCB is going live as a
routing engine now in q4 2019 but
importantly
next quarter we will expand the range of
what we do today this is a first I'd say
limited version where we would like to
engage with you know the hobbyist
the PCB hobbies community get their
feedback about the type of features they
want and ultimately scale to larger BOTS
today we limit it to 150 like
connections in the future it will be in
the thousands and we are scaling up our
systems and ultimately this point was
mentioned by Anna Beal earlier you know
routing is just one side of the problem
we believe the future is having AI
systems that can learn by themselves how
to solve place and route like how do you
place the components you can see this as
another sequential set of actions that
you are doing before you go to routing
but fundamentally the scalable no
heuristics from first principles type
technology that we are developing with
our partners will allow groundbreaking
results in that so stay tuned for that
so that's for for next year but I
believe it's important to provide some
visibility and clarity about where we
are heading with this innovative product
and we're very excited about it another
reason why we're very excited about it
is that we decided to open this to the
community so G PCB is free in its
current version with up to 250 pins 150
rat's nest and 2 layers and it we know
the goal is to engage with the community
learn together build up the tools that
people need to be able to ship their
product to market and importantly ship
it faster and at smaller cost so it's an
exciting time for us feel free to log in
into the live the platform
it's a first-come first-serve because
you know we had to put limits on
capacity but we will be very keen on
interacting with you know PCB users
answering their requests
hearing from them we have a lot to learn
we're very humble that this is the
beginning of the road and it's an
exciting road but we still there's a lot
to do so this is a starting point and
would like to engage with the community
and hopefully get some feedback but you
know there is potential and it's an
exciting time so if I were to
summarize where we are today you know
PCBs we've seen PCBs are solved manually
you know which is time-consuming the
reason why they're solved manually it's
not for the lack of roto-rooter's is the
fact that auto rooters are not good
enough and the reason why they're not
good enough is that they use limited
sets of heuristics and as a consequence
and we've seen a practical example they
may not necessarily connect all in the
components making it pretty much like
limited in terms of utility so people
end up doing it themselves as you've
seen this user who said I do it myself
or with some you know software plus my
insights and then I check the auto
Rooter and it cannot connect more than
80% of the of the of the pair's so so
Auto rooters are very limited and we
believe the future are disruptive
products like gee PCB which are you know
from designed from first principles keep
learning these are systems that learn
all the time and importantly are fully
scalable they are end-to-end there are
there is no human in the loop so the
system can learn by itself at scale and
the more it will you know you know have
experiences the better will be the
results so we're very excited about this
the PCB starts in beta version today and
is free and so we're really like looking
at this exciting next step for instead
deep I have to mention that this is the
first for us first it's the first time
we do a live stream so for those who are
listening if the live stream is working
thanks a lot for for being here but we
believe that it's an interesting step
because ability to deploy powerful
technology such as deep reinforcement
learning not only for games but for real
industrial applications that are
important on which people spend
tremendous amount of time to ship their
product to market we believe this is
very exciting and we're looking forward
to to the journey finally I wanted to
thank our tech partners with who helped
us and supported us along this way
if you had tell me like three four years
ago like you know what instead deep
would be capable of as a startup founded
in Africa that too one day we would be
able to build disrupt
products that have never been shipped to
market before and we believe again this
is a first even though it's a limited
version it is at first well we're very
humbled by the extraordinary amount of
progress and excitement that we've seen
in in internally and the great work that
the team has been doing and it's also
thanks to our partners we've received
you know a lot of support a lot of
positive feedback lots of opportunities
had we thought in the past that we could
collaborate with deepmind be a partner
with Nvidia and Intel know yet it
happened and it shows you that in
today's world if you are passionate
about what you do magic truly can happen
so we want to thank you know everybody
who's been helpful on this way and
finally last point we are hiring so if
you are interested by reinventing the
world of electronics design please
contact us you have all the details
thanks a lot for listening to us and I
think we can take some questions
thank you so we have a microphone and I
believe also on a live stream you we can
post questions on on YouTube as well yes
any questions don't be sorry yes go
ahead
so we have a mic so I might have been
missing something first of all thank you
for a great presentation and within AI
so well so when you place this over you
do the routing how do you learn from it
to the next time you place the routing
or the learning mechanism where does
that come in and the self learning
mechanism okay so yeah perfect so it
comes from like you are gonna do
something like so how does it start the
system starts completely random the
first thing is gonna do is probably not
a good solution but basically you can
rank if the solution is good or not
because depending on how many pairs
connected the length of secretary--
other variables that are
and for how people root PCBs you'll be
able to say this is a good solution or
this is not a good solution so in a
sense this is the needle in a haystack
problem if I show you the needle and say
this until you say yes I found the
needle but the problem is where is the
needle and these are combinatorially
explosive sets of solutions so on a
problem like gee PCB on a large board
you have way more solutions than what we
do would get in the game of go for
example which was famously solved by
deep mind two years ago so there is a
huge space and the question is not
necessarily like how do I rank a good
solution not you know we can come up
with reasonably decent ways to rank the
problem is how do you do it like you
find them and this comes to really like
technicalities of different forcement
learning but I'll give you just the
general intuition the general intuition
is like you know I'm gonna do lots of
stuff you know it might not be great but
some solution will be maybe better than
others and so if I tweak my system
remember this is a neural network
ultimately that governed this so neural
network has tons of parameters as if I
tweak my system slightly through a back
propagation to say hey this was a good
solution can you increase a little bit
the probability that this could happen
again that's the way you learn you know
and actually at in study we've been
innovative in that field or our two
algorithm that we published last year
got us significant feedback from the
research AI research community including
David silver it led also to engagements
we now work with very large companies
such as Deutsche Bahn and complex in
this case routing trains so but the idea
is in the end you trying several things
you find something with slightly better
than what you're doing somewhere else
and if you're doing slightly worse you
reduce the probability and you iterate
that is the general principle again in
AI I would say in most cases the general
principles are easy to understand but to
execute those it's extremely hard to
make any type of progress in a deep
error type system is considered today
very difficult you need experts in
multiple domains
applied mathematicians engineer and like
coding for experts but also experts of
developing sister like deploying systems
at scales literally hundreds if not
thousands of machines that work together
to get to a solution and today we've
reached that critical mass at instead
deep and this is why we're excited about
it because we can innovate fundamentally
and scientifically with patterns
deposited but also deploy that
innovation to customers which I believe
is the second part of the equation that
most people sometimes forget like it's
all about getting your hands dirty and
getting it to work and this is why we're
excited about this milestone today so
another question do you use your so do
you have an advantage of this yourself
do you using those boards in your own
calculations well we'd love to but we're
not we haven't reached that size yet yes
but you're right there is there is a
feedback loop there that if you are
developing more efficient boards
ultimately you can deploy more machine
learning compute and iterate from there
I would say today who could be doing
that you know maybe Google could be
doing that but it still still it's in
safe hands it's in its infancy like it
takes years to develop an advanced chip
when it comes to like the ones like such
as the one Google has which is a Google
cloud CPU one so it takes years but what
is certain though is that using modern
machine learning to improve the design
of chips could significantly shorten the
delay to innovate and ship in the next
like product or the next version of that
supercomputer so you could see just to
give you an idea something that today is
maybe taking three four years I
personally would not be surprised in the
next five years
you know the delay to market and from
design to market and production using
production is probably like two years
like could you reduce that amount of
time by 50% I believe you could and that
is significant and it's the same for you
know PC be like developers some of them
many small companies with whom were
interacting we've actually spoken to
some of them we believe that we could
significantly shorten their time to
market if you think
that in many cases you're pushing a
product every year to market this new
version like this new version of iPhone
and there's a new version of many things
every year if you could shorten that
development cycle by 2 to 3 months
that's massive
that's 25% of time that you have saved
so we're looking at significant
industrial efficiencies there as we
develop and scale those innovative
systems yes well one question yeah this
is on yes okay so I'm an instant
employee just for full disclosure but
just I wanted to maybe ask a bit and
maybe prompt a bit about when you talk
about RL a lot of the successes so far
were in this place where there were
existing environments so I'm not a terry
game or an Unreal Engine or the go board
which is kind of very simple to
implement but in this case you needed to
have access to a simulator that's
industry compliant and so in a way it
was kind of writing your own computer
game from scratch I was going to tell a
bit more about how much of that was
in-house and how much of that was
external software in terms of the
simulator and the board modeling yeah
yeah thank you and by the way that's
Marek who's ex-google did mind were very
happy to have him in our team so so
basically the interesting point here is
that we've essentially built everything
ourselves and I'm actually really
impressed by the performance of four
team working across multiple locations
in in London in Tunisia in North Africa
and in Paris in France being able to
deliver on a complex as we said
industrial product like this in that
kind of amount of time is is truly
remarkable our point of view on this is
we believe that small teams can actually
be competitive in in in this time and
age with large companies if they truly
collaborate and act together as I said
AI requires larger teams
I personally don't believe that AI
progress can be
really driven when you're talking about
industrial products by a couple of
people but a tightly knit team of 10 to
15 extremely motivated employees can
really deliver wonders and when you mix
the domain expertise we have thanks to
Anna Beale Orly the hardware engineer
and his team with the advanced different
learning innovation that we have for our
existing team as well like it's it's
truly remarkable and actually I want to
really say I'm really blown away by how
motivated passionate the team has been
as I believe they're at their fourth
weekend without taking any rest so that
we could deliver this presentation to
you so really like well done guys and it
shows you the potential and hopefully we
take it from there and continue to
improve you know so well don't get I
don't know if we have any questions
online yes we have a fume okay so we'll
start with further down the line how
would you qualify your unique selling
proposition as a routing specialist in a
few hours versus a few weeks or just
better than the best routing specialist
or maybe both yeah I think you know in
general like what instead deep what
we've discovered because we didn't have
this ambition to start with what we've
discovered is that we could be
innovative and go beyond in certain
cases the state of the art when it comes
to industrial applications of deeper
enforcement learning we are a bootstrap
so we've learnt from day one to listen
to customers and solve their problems
otherwise we wouldn't be here but at the
same time with the innovation capability
we have we can now really have a go at
complex problems and yes those are
around the decision making
you know they involve routing in many
cases so were active in logistics were
now very active in electronic design so
there is a commonality around those and
so yes the goal would be to deliver a
great solution potentially as good if
not better of what exists already but
importantly save time like we've spoken
to users and actually Nabeel and and the
team sat down with multiple
actually designers of PCB boards people
who ship their own hardware in the u.s.
they build it in China they ship it in
your in the US and Europe and the
feedback was the key element is the
cycle time if we can reduce cycle time
that is a massive homerun for those
developers and of course the solution
needs to be at a level of quality which
is acceptable ideally it's even better
than what others do but if you can
reduce cycle time with an acceptable
solution from weeks or months in 2 to 24
hours this is this is incredible this is
truly disruptive AI at its best and
today at instant if you believe it's
possible this is the first step we're
doing with the D PCB so if you try the
PCB you'll be able to get results in 24
hours no matter what you sound provided
it's within the limits that we set but
in the future we're going to expand to
more and more complex ports so yes we
believe that we can significantly help
thank you we also have one more
specifically on the tool if you can
reiterate the tools that have been used
to build the solution so really like
we've built it from scratch it sounds
incredible to say but actually we
haven't used any particular tool one of
the reasons is we actually have experts
of high performance computing in the
team and also they were they were
certain ways were in which we had to
design basically the routing system such
that it would be fully compatible with
deep reinforcement learning and advanced
AI and I believe that's the future I'm
not necessarily convinced that legacy
tools which haven't been designed with
AI in mind and end-to-end cloud
scalability are necessarily the way
forward and they will probably need to
be reinvented by people who really have
a good sense of what is required from
both a scientific point of view but also
like an engineering and high performance
computing point of view and this is
actually critical for success let's put
it in this way like if you have a great
tool but it's super slow there is no way
you're going to be able to deploy deep
reinforcement learning because these
math
are extremely like you know heavy in
terms of like number of experiences you
need to accumulate to get to results if
you do not understand the specifics of
the problem and how to crack it in ways
that make it like amenable to deeper L
type technologies that's going to be a
problem so I believe actually this is
one of the reasons why were among the
very few who can deliver this kind of
products and to and is you really need
to mix those competences but once were
strictly a question now we did not use
any existing tools so this is genuinely
new and innovative and just to touch a
little bit further on what you kind of
already said if the piece B is a fully
RL based tool or just include also a
heuristic methods to optimize routing
and this is what we are really excited
about this is the first pure AI di rail
powered system in the market and so this
is to our knowledge and please correct
us if we're wrong it's a world first and
we're very excited about it so there is
literally no heuristic which is built in
the system to sort of like tweak certain
sets of solution versus others the
system tries to be as rational it can be
an example of that line of thinking is
like what garry kasparov said about
chess when alpha zero came up and
basically did stock fish and all
existing software systems existing and
in a couple of hours like in four hours
alpha zero learned to beat stock fish
which was at the time the best software
system for chess garry kasparov said I'm
really excited about alpha zero because
in certain way it's it represents the
truth so it has no bias and so as a
consequence this the style of play is
sort of the right way but also he said
that because alpha zero is very
aggressive like Kasparov used to play so
he wanted to say that but this is kind
of a line of thinking we try to avoid
heuristics and I think that's the reason
why those systems eventually will be way
more powerful than any existing
autoroute are in the market today I mean
we know Auto rooters are bad today it's
not us saying that is literally users
and so we believe you know it's a
significant most
that the PCB is now competitive with
Auto Reuters but we believe we can go
way more and way further than that and
that the future is about learning learn
about system where you try to minimize
bias so it's really like in the sort of
like the richard certain way of thinking
which is design a learning algorithm and
let reality and truth reveal itself
progressively those systems will
significantly enhance the
state-of-the-art amazing I think we only
have one more before we have to cut it
so I just want to finish with would you
publish any benchmark versus industry
proven routing and placement tools yes a
good question definitely will work on
benchmarks to be very clear and very
humble this is just a first at this is
our beta so we're not claiming that
we've solved all the problems we're
claiming that this is an interesting
angle that we believe has not been
explored or at least in a publicly
available product before and so we are
actually very interested in the feedback
of the PCB and hobbyist community and
actually I appreciate those questions
which are very relevant so we'd like to
hear more from you guys but yes in in
the first half of next year we will
definitely publish benchmarks and also
you know I encourage everybody who is
interested to come and use the tool we
have you have available capacity which
is there for free use it give us your
feedback once you've used it is it good
is it bad it certainly can be done
better and it will hopefully but we are
also learning and we're very humble we
have never done this before but we're
very excited about it so hopefully by
collaborating with the open source and
PCB community we can accelerate the
development clock but yes next year we
will definitely publish benchmarks and I
believe those will be very promising
cool again thanks a lot for your time
today and for everybody who's been
following us online it's a first for us
so your feedback is welcome and I hope
there hasn't been too many technical
glitches or no cyber triage or it is not
a big one so thanks a lot for your time
today and looking forward to interacting
with all of you in the future and have a
nice day thanks
[Applause]